it's me Valentina how do you feel about this top 4 is it the top four you kind of pictured - you not being in it I don't really care fan-favorite Valentina stepping out for the finale taping of RuPaul's Drag Race Season 9 the slammer I mean tonight I'm wearing Oscar de la Renta my shoes are by Dolce & Gabbana I just feel at my ultimate most powerful version of me and that is being Valentina oh she doesn't know the words do you know the words to greedy now he'll mother now do you do whatever you want I mean it's Ariana Grande it's greedy you should know that Ariana Grande Valentina this lip-sync for your life we need to see your lips take that thing off of your mouth I'd like to keep it on please it's a lip-sync what part of that do not understand any regrets about the season not one not one [Music] you